hey this is presh talwalkar
here's a fun logic test
if it were two hours later it would be
half as long until midnight
as it would be if we're an hour later
than it is now
what time is it now
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's work through this step by step
let x be the current time
if it were two hours later the time
would be x plus two
at that time it would be half as long
until midnight
let's use 24 hour time so that midnight
is represented by 24.
the time to midnight two hours later
will be 24 minus the quantity x plus 2.
at that time it would be
half as long until midnight so we want
to set this equation to half as long as
another quantity of time
that will be
if it were one hour later than it is now
so we want the time to midnight
and one hour later is x plus one
we now have an equation and we need to
solve for x
we'll first simplify the parentheses
then we'll multiply by 2 on both sides
we'll distribute
now we'll bring the x terms to the right
hand side and the constant terms to the
left-hand side so we get 21 is equal to
x
this corresponds to 2100 hours or 9 p.m
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you